in the Tokyo suburb of Seti gaya visit
temple to Japan's inventive ways it's
the home / laboratory of dr. Nakamatsu
you know you're famous when you've got
your own Street Avenue and square right
outside your house dr. Nakamatsu achieve
celeb status through his numerous
inventions walking into his house is
like stepping into a QVC graveyard of
forgotten and obscure gadgets
some of his inventions are legit many
years ago he patented the floppy disk
and a popular suction device used
throughout homes in Japan dr. Nakamatsu
you for having us here
Oh welcome they're coming to Japan and
the welcome to dr. Nakamatsu house I was
reading that you invented the floppy
disk the CD the fax machine the drone
why do you think you don't get credit
for all of these inventions yeah because
I'm always looking new things I'm
working Saturday Sunday holiday yeah I
have no holiday in addition to being a
pro at dodging questions the good
doctors biggest claim to fame as having
more patents than anyone else Thomas SR
made 1093 and he did that 84 I am now 88
my number is 3500 and this is still
increasing because I'm still living ya
know it's incredible but not all of dr.
Nakamatsu inventions are addison esque
this is a weapon inside and when you
have somebody coming at this this is dr.
Nakamatsu Otter this pitar changed
pata technologies this pata can control
board direction and distance
the doctor has even developed an
over-the-counter solution for one of
Japan's biggest economic problems in
Japan the population is decreasing and
decreasing this is Rob jet
but the forebrain makes visible six and
this rabbit no needle for free just the
spray